über schallt flugzeuge wie die concorde
Ja die sind teuer klein und laut drei gründe warum sie nicht mehr fliegen doch kommt jetzt die trendwende können wir bald alle
mit überschall in extrem kurzer zeit zwischen den kontinenten reisen unter anderem entwickelt die nasa mit dem sogenannten schlieren effekt
überschallflugzeugen die viel leiser sind wie funktioniert diese technik genau und bedeutet dass jetzt tatsächlich schon bald die rückkehr der superschnellen
passagierflugzeuge ein wirklich spannendes thema das ihr euch bei whatsapp gewünscht
Habt wie ihr da hin kommt übrigens weder whatsapp seit das erfahrt, am ende, des videos also herzlich willkommen bei konstanz entwickeln
Muss erst mal klarzustellen der sogenannte schlieren effekt hat nichts mit missglückten versuchen die fenster schlierenfrei zu putzen zu tun
tatsächlich wurde dieses verfahren vor mehr als 150 jahren von einem deutschen physiker erfunden damit war es erstmals möglich
Dichte unterschiede in der luft auf fotoplatten sichtbar zu machen
die sogenannten schlieren platt gesagt kann man durch diesen effekt
Also das sichtbar machen was das menschliche auge normalerweise nicht wahrnehmen kann die luftdichte und ihre veränderungen
Im alltag also dinge wie die warme luft beim haare föhnen oder aber die wärme die entsteht wenn man die hände aneinander reibt oder
Heizungsluft auf die nasa an nutzt dieses verfahren und hat es weiterentwickelt so ist es tatsächlich gelungen bei modernen
überschalljets die druckwelle sichtbar zu machen also den berühmten überschallknall und das unter realistischen
umständen und das ist ziemlich schwierig aus diesen aufnahmen unter anderem sind leise
überschallflugzeugen jetzt in greifbare
Nähe gerückt aber von vorne normalerweise ist eben ein lauter knall zu hören wenn ein düsenflugzeug die schallmauer durchbricht
seismometer können das festhalten denn die druckwelle
Des knalls erschüttert den erdboden das ist wirklich absoluter wahnsinn früher da konnte man das immer mal wieder hören
irgend unglaublich laut und das rumpf so richtig doch diese dichte variationen der luft auf fotos festzuhalten
das war lange nicht möglich nur in modellen
Im windkanal die entsprechenden testflüge der nasa fanden in der mojave wüste in südkalifornien stadt pro shooting
waren zwei flugzeuge beteiligt eines der flugzeuge hatte die aufgabe die schallmauer zu durchbrechen und eine
entsprechende druckwelle zu erzeugen und zwar abwechselnd die flugzeugtypen f-15 und t 38
Darüber flog das zweite flugzeug das eine kamera installiert hatte und in diesem nasa versuch ist es eine king
er die deutlich langsamer ist und eben nicht in der lage die schallmauer, zu durchbrechen
vor allem die navigation der flugzeuge war heikel und nicht ungefährlich denn sie dürften sich trotz der großen
geschwindigkeitsdifferenz nicht so weit voneinander entfernen damit gute bildqualität
Überhaupt möglich wurde die eingesetzte kamera war in der lage
109 bilder pro sekunde zu machen ein
Absolutes unterfangen das alles möglich zu machen hatte die nasa die herkömmliche methode namens boss aus dem windkanal
weiter entwickelt bosch steht für
background oriented schweren der name des nasa projekts dementsprechend auch airbus die
bildbearbeitung an sich war dagegen weniger spektakulären die einzelnen frames wurden per laptop
ausgewertet und viele einzel fenstern zusammengesetzt und diese neue
aufnahmetechnik liefert nicht nur atemberaubende bilder sondern konnte auch zeitnah in der praxis genutzt werden denn bisher ist es
überschallflüge
Nicht nur in den usa sondern auch in deutschland verboten über bewohnten regionen zu fliegen früher war das anders da konnte man eben noch
den überschallknall ab und zu hören und zwar eben wegen dieser lärmbelästigung die nase erhoffte sich also durch diese neue
aufnahmetechnik deutlich leisere
Überschallflugzeuges zu konstruieren und tatsächlich scheint es so als sei die nasa diesem ziel
ziemlich näher gekommen zu sein vielleicht wissen dass die nasa-ingenieure
teams haben explain ein flugzeugmodell entwickelt bei dem die schockwellen deutlich abgeschwächt sind die bezeichnungen
supersonic transport, im gegensatz zur concorde selten dieses passagierflugzeug dieses überschall passagierflugzeug
nur einen weichen schuss abgeben wenn es die schallmauer durchbricht die concorde brauchte für die strecke new york/paris ja nur
knapp drei stunden
2003 wurde sie dann aber eingestellt weil die sicherheitsbedenken wegen des absturzes zu groß und die nachfrage auch eher klein weil die flüge
waren tierisch teuer
Aber eine miniatur version des neuen nasa überschallflugzeuges wurde schon im windkanal getestet
Anfang, des monats macht in die nasa dann ernst und beauftragte den rüstungskonzern lockheed martin
Explain zu entwerfen zu bauen und zu testen zwei
147,5 millionen dollar ist der nasa das wert der plan explain soll in 16.000 kilometern
Höhe fliegen und zwar mit 1500 kilometern pro stunde seine spezielle bauform soll dann den lauten knall fehler und zwar indem die
schallwellen nicht miteinander verschmelzen sondern in kleine stücke zerteilt werden
im jahr 2022 soll dann das endgültige
Passagierflugzeug getestet werden dass für die bevölkerung auf der erde nicht lauter. Sein soll als eine zufallende autotür oder ein donnergrollen hammer
Überschallflüge rücken also wieder in greifbare. Nähe und
Möglich gemacht hat das die schweren fotografie das ist schon irre wenn ihr als erstes neues zum fortschritt bei den
Überflügen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr können dort auch mitmachen und mir zum beispiel
themen vorschlagen usw zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch dort blicken flughafen der zukunft ansonsten bis dann
bleibt